thank you
[Music]
actually did you guys hear about what
happened in the National Football League
or the NFL oh the guy that just the guy
from the Buffalo Bills player Demar
Hamlin what position did he play he
played a I think he's a safety oh [ __ ]
and he
um suffered cardiac arrest on the field
or that's what it looked like while they
were playing yeah well they were playing
he like tackled the guy down
smash them to the floor stood up just
like every other like like football
player like rebounded and then just fell
backwards whoa but you can see how the
dude's helmet like hitting him like
right in like the chin area it was like
well and the chest he gets hit he's hit
hard in the chest right so that's but
you also see that happen every game all
the time yeah they said there was like a
textbook takedown right there's nothing
weird about it right so thankfully he's
he they removed his breathing tube he's
currently breathing on his own and oh
nice he just spoke to his teammates via
video conference yesterday and
apparently he has his mental facilities
which people were very nervous about
yeah so very good news I saw a story
that he woke up and he asked the first
thing he asked was like did we win did
we win the game did he really yeah yeah
yeah and then the doctor and then the
quote was the doctor says yes you won
you won the game of life that's what the
did he say that yeah that's what the
doctor said I heard that episode
this [ __ ] they're like yo if he wakes up
I'm [ __ ] save it if he said oh I'm
gonna say this and then they're just
waiting for that moment he's like yeah
but that doesn't set me up for Super
Bowl season what the [ __ ] are you
talking about I heard you should get
resuscitated twice what I heard that the
yeah the guys on field like the bills
player Personnel the CPR saved his ass
like him mouth to mouth like hardcore
they are saved so dude yeah I'm glad he
wasn't homophobic
[Laughter]
fully goes through training and still
has 50 50 chances on whether or not
they're going to use their skills didn't
Andrew Tate say he would never do
mouth-to-mouth yep
don't do that man wait who said that I
mean I wouldn't want to accept it either
I'd just rather die because the medic
was probably thinking hey I'm here for
the cheerleaders okay if they need it
I'll help them out but other than that
[ __ ] that well if there's no girls
watching I would do it yeah but if
there's girls watching then that would
be terrifying or if there's gay guys
watching yeah oh that's true too because
they're all gonna want you yeah
that's a nice situation
um classic CPR situation so obviously
this is great news right so yeah that's
great so what happened to him
um they're calling like a bad luck
moment where he got hit at a certain
moment in his cardiac cycle like where
his his heart is like you know [ __ ]
pumping right and like just before it's
like it's about to pump again he gets
hit in the chest and it shocks his heart
and that's what caused him to have fun I
don't even know that was a thing you
gotta get it at the the
it's like it's like they were saying
it's like a millisecond indifference of
timing called kamoshio Cordis I believe
I nailed that yeah
um and it it set off with doctors called
ventricular
ventricular Force nailed it v-fib it
sounds like a crypto which I would buy
yeah this sounds like something you
would hear at like in like an old
Chinese kung fu movie
you get it
guys
so um his heartbeat was restored through
CPR and um then he was put into a
medically induced coma
um and yeah they did they do that they
do that to protect his brain because
when you have the CPR as he had for 10
minutes or so the blood supply to the
brain gets limited and you don't want
the brain to suffer or shut down at all
so he loses facilities so people were
very happy that he woke up and has shown
like he remembered he was a bills player
and who he is and all that stuff like
that yeah you guys you guys CPR
certified I am I have to be I was when I
was a kid wait what
did you forget that the policies have
changed a lot actually over the years
the policies that was so I was like what
I mean like you because they actually
that's what you have to keep getting oh
before I forgot I forgot what it was
yeah you have to do whatever and then
then I remember as I got older when I
got it again it was like just keep going
for right the newest one is like it's 30
and two now it's like if someone is like
15 and serious but not someone's that's
right you just keep going until the
paramedics come or some [ __ ] right and
keep providing yeah you just keep
providing before there was like What if
they're like get the [ __ ] off me well
he's dead he's a guy if you could talk
to you he's good you know what's so
funny we're at the gym I'm gay
at the gym one of the guys came he's
like he's one of the members and he's
like hey guys I got you guys a gift for
the gym and we're like cool what is it
and it was an AED machine oh really
using those with the cabinets we have
one and I was like it's it's uh oh
what the heck and I was like why do you
just have one of these you know and he
was like yeah I just got one for my
company I just brought in for you guys
so we just have a new ad machine so it's
all the perks of the gym we're not
pretty cool we just called it the heart
thingy
yeah I call it a thing from ET yeah yeah
when my buddy was uh overdosing I saw
that [ __ ] like they used it on them
right they threw a tube down his mouth
it was like a long tube yeah like he
deep throated that so the first thing
that came to my mind yeah
dude it's like troubling I don't want
any part of this yeah he ripped this
[ __ ] I was just like the cop was talking
to me the whole time I'm just like damn
dude your throat is deep Bro and then
after that they [ __ ] bust a thing on
them and the Joe's like damn your throat
is deep Bro I was like dude no that will
it was like this there was a whole ass
Boba straw that went down this and then
the two people say it's a little too big
actually or something like that and then
afterwards
I was like yo I never seen this [ __ ]
like this is all the movies like The
Dude are they gonna [ __ ] do it for
real and then they [ __ ] brought them
back like and I was like oh [ __ ] could
do some bad news your friend is alive
[Laughter]
is safe which is great news right out of
the woods the big question now in the
National Football League as we approach
Super Bowl season playoffs is who won
that game who won the game so the NFL
because they just pause the game right
pause the game and didn't bring it back
they didn't reschedule it oh oh for real
betting markets were [ __ ] right people
had to have their money spent back at
them and then
um their playoff seating so it's all
about playoff seating at this point
right so how many wins you have versus
other teams in the brackets and who gets
home field position which is a huge
Advantage because you have your home
crowd there yelling at the other team
calling [ __ ] and [ __ ] the whole
time and it gets in their head and [ __ ]
with them right and we all know about
the mental game of any sport anything so
it works pretty well like home games
usually benefit the home team so
um
now
um this has kind of [ __ ] with things
because it's basically a stalemate
so Kansas City is it's looking like
they're going to have home field
advantage through the playoffs but the
NFL's talking about perhaps hosting
um the the game at a neutral site if if
the Chiefs make it to the AFC
Championship game they would host it
like say at the cult Stadium I think the
culture said no actually because there's
like a volleyball tournament some some
stupid oh I did see that yeah yeah yeah
something stupid honestly we sucked so
much this year I don't want football in
that Stadium why can't they uh like redo
the game is that like not part so people
were saying loud well people were saying
like why don't we do a week 19 game
because this week is the the last week
of regular season football right so a
week 19 game would make it so like
there's nobody playing except for
there's playoff teams like that weekend
so why don't they do that they have
plenty of stadiums open but um the NFL
chose a stalemate for whatever reason so
why out of they stop the game I've never
heard of them doing that me either I've
never heard that in sports history was
there like so it was
the heart attack like it was because
yeah because I think the players were so
traumatized but it was so [ __ ] up and
they've spoken about this now right and
even other players who were watching
like Aaron Rodgers and people who were
watching like the big guys were saying
like it shook him to the core like but
is that like I feel like is that
something the older I mean not even to
be funny or anything but was that
something like the older generations of
football players would call these guys
[ __ ] I think that we're not finishing
leatherheads a guy almost dying on the
field is different than like a guy like
you know turn his ACL yeah yeah yeah but
I feel like like in the UFC like let's
say Nick socks me and kills me I feel
like Urban Dino would just be like
there hasn't been a death in NFL before
from any anything not that I'm aware of
but it could be I don't think on the
field because of this whole thing about
CT and everything they thought it could
be that or like well there's been an
extra sensitivity towards CTE especially
since the NFL got busted for covering
all that [ __ ] up a couple years back
right Will Smith who can tell the truth
but you know but that's the only thing I
remember that movie's boring as [ __ ] so
boring
um but that part I remember but dude no
it's one of those things where I think
that the league is trying to
overcompensate now for that because they
[ __ ] up so bad I see and so there's a
over like precaution we're very safe
this is a safe sport so if a player goes
down and then if any rep if any ref sees
like like maybe their eyes are dilated
or something like that they can pull
them and they could make them go through
a protocol like to to test for
concussions yeah one of the most
beautiful scenes I saw was um after
tomorrow hit the ground both teams were
like on their knees yeah yeah yeah it
was just like it was like dude this is
so crazy that like this has nothing to
do with rivalry or the game it's just
being humans yeah as humans holy [ __ ]
what is happening and like everyone was
just like their forehead it was really
cool and every you know NFL team I think
on their Twitter like changed their
profile to his number and I think you
know
I'm putting like you know we have like a
30-yard line yeah and we like because
his number is number three so we like
outlined it with like red so it looks
like his jersey it's like a cool [ __ ]
like that's going on dude that would
suck so much if like in the future the
the bills are like losing and the coach
goes I need you to do that heart thing
like the way that they use fouls now
that would be so [ __ ] sad get a heart
flop what was the score when he uh when
the when it happened remember that's a
good question they should just go by
that huh yeah right like I didn't
continue on that crazy but you can come
back we've seen crazy no dude not past
halftime not after the third quarter
back basketball
yeah it ain't golf Will Smith better
bets
don't don't look it up don't look it up
no I'm pretty sure you're quoting Will
Smith movies [ __ ] Legend of Bagger
Vance man
Will Smith movies oh it was seven it was
seven to three Cincy see anything happen
how much time they got left yeah
um anything could have happened yeah see
plenty of time and the bills weren't
they balling out aren't they don't they
have a really crazy ball not all year
but since he has come on late like
what's their record what's since he's
record right now I think it's like 35
and 10 wins
is Andy Dalton still the quarterback no
what the [ __ ] you don't know who Joe
burrow is oh Joe burrow eleven and four
um I've been following football I know
Andy Dalton though but next week is
playoffs Joe Montana
Ventura
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]